good morning everyone my name is Todd
read board along with my partner drug
Pearlman from walnut capital where the
developers of bakery square we welcome
everyone here we debated a little bit
about whether to have the 10 or not on a
day today and I guess we guessed wrong
but it's a beautiful day here in
Pittsburgh and we'll have the blue skies
which we'll see in a few minutes when we
go across the street for the
groundbreaking we are the lead
developers of bakery square and along
with our partners at the rcg Longview
fun we're here today to officially
commence the start of construction for
bakery square 2 point 0 first office
building but before we cross the street
in unearthed some of the dirt we're
going to take a little bit of time to
talk about the enormous success we've
had here at bakery square and the meat
and then the immense opportunities that
lie ahead of us pittsburgh has truly
come a long way since 2006 and we began
the process of historically renovating
this old Nabisco building that had been
sitting here for almost 100 years while
some saw a decaying seven-story vacant
bakery in transitional neighborhood we
saw an immense opportunity to
strategically develop this property and
help catalyze these neighborhoods into
the bus bustling places that they once
were all of you in the audience our
public officials are university leaders
are financing friends that are here
today shared our vision for bakery
square that vision was very simple it
was built it right and they will come
that that is really what drove this
development building it right meant
carefully putting the pieces of a
quality-of-life mixed-use development
together what that included building an
innovative urban office space with an
industrial feel kind of this hip
shopping with social activities and
sustainable eco-friendly infrastructure
and residences building in right was
critical because the the top tier
companies that came here we knew we
would attract simply wouldn't come if
the young brains out of Carnegie Mellon
and the university of pits were going to
across the world weren't attracted to
this type of development so together we
put together a hip and innovative
world-class development that as we're
sitting here today
has created over a thousand full-time
high-paying quality of life type jobs
successfully have trekked attracting the
best and the brightest so you're going
to hear a lot about that later so why
not continue this momentum that's really
the challenge here while we get ready to
celebrate bakery squares expansion with
new office space at bakery square 2
point 0 and the residence is a bakery
living it's important that we recognize
how we got here because to be truthful
making our vision was a reality really
wasn't easy it was a tough tough tough
road to hoe but sitting here today we're
glad we did it I'd not like to introduce
my partner Greg Pearlman to talk a
little more about bakery square
construction for bakery square began in
late two thousand seven with our friend
and visionary quirky cost who's here
today starting this impressive masonary
rehabilitation of this beautiful
building just months later the economy
tanked and what was one of the biggest
recession since the Great Depression
major funders and retailers backed out
of the project we had serious
discussions with our partners to
mothball the project until the recession
was over but with preference and strong
partnerships we didn't turn the oven off
we kept baking all our public community
and university officials with us today
played an immense role in ensuring
bakeries revitalization Todd and I know
the development world pretty well we
truly don't believe this development
could have ever happened in any other
city but Pittsburgh because no other
city has the strong public-private
partnership that Pittsburgh does we have
dedicated governmental leaders
foundations and in particular we have
world-class universities who play a key
role in the creation of a university
centered economic ecosystem igniting
these partnerships around a shared
vision we continue to raise the bar on
accomplishing amazing things like the
transformation of a vacant school across
the street into to be able to have
bakeries two point oh before I introduce
Todd who will introduce the speakers
again I
going to briefly talk about the office
project at bakery to point o we have
250,000 square feet of Austin's bake
right here next to us we've outgrown it
it's a hundred percent full and I want
to thank all our amazing tenants for
this happening UPMC Google University of
Pittsburgh VA and Carnegie Mellon bakery
2 point 0 will triple the amount of
office space but it won't just be any
old office space it will be the best
high quality lead certified space in
Pittsburgh and probably the nation
strategically located next to prime
retail and residential space a
neighborhood experience great wreath
birth within a two-mile radius from the
eds and meds economic powerhouses of the
universities the first building we're
building offers 218 thousand square feet
of space and Google has already signed a
lease to occupy one third of it the
overall development will create over
2,000 new high paying full time jobs 218
construction jobs and 429 spin-off jobs
while providing millions of tax revenues
to the city county school district and
state as you can see we're moving pretty
fast Construction has already begun on
the 12-acre project once how's the old
vacan rise of sign school and in
addition to the plan four hundred
twenty-five thousand square feet of
total office space we will also we have
350 brand new rental apartment buildings
along with 52 townhomes the first
hundred and seventy-five unit which is
right there will open bakery libram open
this June we have six weeks to go so PJ
dick better get working
that's for you Frank it's on the line
it's in the news as you can see the
renderings next to me this space has
been carefully ray engineered and will
be remarkable it will be green it will
have be pedestrian-friendly bike access
points that connect both developments
and our surrounding neighborhoods of
East Liberty Larimore shadyside and leed
certified buildings that boasts like
green storm water management systems
green groups and courtyards a beautiful
and elegant sky bridge will connect both
bakery one and bakery to across Penn
Avenue so Todd it's time to introduce
our speakers thank you we have a very
fantastic lineup of folks here today
first I'd like to introduce our
congressman mike doyle as we talked
about staying ahead of the game is what
we're all about here at bakery to play
no Mike was extremely instrumental in
bringing two million dollars of federal
money and Ed a grant to our region
really the first major ed a grant and I
know Mike's been a great supporter of
this project and the whole economy here
and I'd like to bring them up and say a
few words Thanks well I'll tell you it's
been a good couple days I yesterday we
had the President and the Vice President
here in the Pittsburgh region the pens
won the first game of the playoffs the
weather got nice here we are at bakery
square you know my staff wrote me a
wonderful speech which I'm not going to
read but I still make them write it any
way to keep them practiced I just want
to reflect a little bit on on how things
like this are possible in this region
and and why the president likes to come
to Pittsburgh as often as he does you
know it's a little bit you get a little
bit emotional if you lived in this area
I grew up just a couple miles down the
road here and remember the Nabisco
bakery here remember when there wasn't a
nabisco bakery just a vacant building
and attempts to resurrect it failed and
and this whole chord
was was almost at times like a war zone
and and you just thought what is ever
going to happen people just sort of
avoided saying the name East Liberty and
now you look at East Liberty and all the
development that's taken place and
bakery square the original bakery square
really what was the start of the
resurrection of this region and the
reason it can happen in Pittsburgh and
it doesn't happen a lot of other places
Rory Cooper and I were just talking
about this beforehand we're a pragmatic
bunch of folks here in western
Pennsylvania we really don't care to see
individuals get credit when we work
together and get things done Pittsburgh
gets credit it's the Pittsburgh name
it's this idea this spirit that we work
the business community works with the
labor community here we partner with
academia in the public sector we work as
partners to get things done we share a
common vision we all grew up in this
region we all like one another and and
we want to see things get done we want
to see things get done for Pittsburgh
for our kids for our grandkids because
we're proud of this place we call home
and it happens here because of that kind
of spirit and that kind of cooperation
that you see amongst all the people that
helped make this project possible and it
attracts people to this region I
remember talking to Andy over at Google
when when they were first building up
here and he was talking about people
they transferred from the West Coast and
come to Pittsburgh and at first they
weren't sure what to expect and whether
or not they could get people to come to
Pittsburgh until they sold those little
garages out in the west coast that they
paid a million dollars for and bought
mansions here for a couple hundred
thousand they thought hey Pittsburgh's
not a bad place to live and then you see
the the cultural men amis we're sort of
like a we're a big small city we have
everything the big city has but we're a
small community to we all know one
another role interconnected with one
another and we all want to see this
region do well because we're so proud of
it that's why bakery squares is a
success here that's why bakery square
2.0 is going to be a smashing
says that's why this corridor is just
another example of what happens when
pittsburghers work together with that
can-do spirit that were famous for
that's why presidents like to come to
western Pennsylvania and show the rest
of the country what Pittsburgh does
congratulations next we're next we're
very honored to have with us dr. subra
Suresh from Carnegie Mellon the new
president and i was talking to dr.
Suresh right before we came in here and
I don't know if anybody in this room was
in his investor inauguration ceremony at
Carnegie Mellon but the speech he gave
about the importance of diversity in
pittsburgh and in our region and
bringing people from the outside and all
working together was something that was
extremely important i think shows the
new Pittsburgh so I think we're very
proud here today to welcome dr. Suresh
and given an opportunity to get say a
few words thank you thank you as a
relative newcomer to Pittsburgh I can
tell you that what attracted me and my
wife Mary to Pittsburgh is the
opportunity to work with nonprofits the
city they elected officials industry and
the community to have an impact on the
region much more so than any president
of any university in different parts of
the country that I have lived in I've
seen have the opportunity to do and this
is something that really attracted us to
come here and if anything in the last 10
months that I've been here that
sentiment has grown further and has been
strengthened so we are really delighted
to be here Carnegie Mellon and the
bakery square have had a very strong
close and historic relationship since
the beginning of the transformation of
this choir and that's going to continue
further it's going to expand
significantly with the creation of
bakery 2 point 0 there are several
things that I can tell you that Carnegie
Mellon is poised to contribute further
to the revitalization of the city &
Bakery 2 point 0 first in the last few
years many independent studies have
acknowledged that CMU spins out more
companies per dollar of federal research
money spend than pretty much every
university in the country this is
literally bang for the buck if the bank
is defined as spinning out companies
secondly in the last couple of years or
so unlike 10 years ago or 20 years ago
we've been able to attract more venture
capital funding for companies that
stayed here than ever before and that
something relatively new as an
institution it's in the top view top
five or so in the country and last but
not least this year CMU faculty alone
will spin out 36 companies and many of
those will stay here that's that's the
new thing that coupled with the fact
that we have a growing population for
the first time in many decades and many
of the growth comes from young people in
the 25 to 35 age group who have a
college degree who are poised to
contribute to the economic success of
the region points to the right direction
we are very grateful to partner with
many entities UPMC Google and others
that are located here I think the
two-way interaction between these
entities and Carnegie Mellon and our
very strong collaboration with the
University of Pittsburgh is critical not
only for bakery to point 0 but also for
the future of Carnegie Mellon last week
congressman Doyle and I participated in
an event at the Kennedy caucus room in
the Senate in Washington DC where we had
a event highlighting how institutions of
higher education transform regions and
why Pittsburgh is a model for their not
only the rest of the country but for
cities as firing to capitalize on the
economic resurgence in different parts
of the world and about 150 people came
to that event and people outside of
western Pennsylvania
those from places like brookings
institution who do research on this
pointed out that pittsburgh has become a
model city for other organizations and
other cities to emulate so it's a great
pleasure and an honor to be part of the
celebration and I very much look forward
to being part of this community and
contributing to the growth of bakery 2
point 0 in the months and years to come
thank you very much thank you now
representing the Commonwealth of
Pennsylvania we have our lieutenant
governor Jim Cawley I must say that the
state has been a tremendous partner of
ours from the very beginning here at
bakery square in a bakery square 2 point
0 from from Richard at the DC dues here
today and his whole staff and everybody
they've really got the message that
we're trying to do here in Pittsburgh as
you've heard and we do think Governor
Corbett and and the entire
administration for all the support
they've given us so now let me introduce
the lieutenant governor Jim Cawley well
following congressman Doyle's lead my
staff to put together a wonderful speech
that will be made available in the back
of the room when you leave ah I was
chatting earlier with my friend and
you're good state senator Jay costum we
were talking about the fact that Jay
grew up in this neighborhood and that as
a young man he would play baseball
probably stealing at least some of his
speech right now but as a young man he
would play baseball across the street
and when the wind was just right you
could smell what was baking at Nabisco I
have a similar story although I did not
grow up in the shadow of a bakery my
cousins did another Nabisco bakery in
the northeast section of Philadelphia
right off of roosevelt boulevard and
there was more than a couple of times
that that I smelled those delicious
smells as well and while the smells here
perhaps have died down the importance
of this ground to this community today
is renewed and made stronger this is a
wonderful thing to see in a community of
people this community of Pittsburgh that
is so deserving to have wonderful things
happen the spirit the vitality all this
community is infectious and it does not
surprise me as the president of CMU said
that people around the country are
looking to Pittsburgh for as an example
looking to Pittsburgh for ideas looking
to Pittsburgh for answers it's very well
deserved and this investment be it the
federal government and congressman we
thank you and please send more checks a
bit bit the state government I promise
we'll try to bring more checks on the
local government as well and I know that
the mayor and the county executive are
here as well it is indeed a team effort
to make something like this a reality
this is an exciting venture it is one
that particularly is of interest to a
son of Pittsburgh who wishes he could be
here himself if all I get to work with
every day who was telling me about this
project and the thing that is most
attractive to the governor and most
attractive to me is how much young
people are going to be a part of all
that is going to be going on here that
marks an investment in the future of
Pittsburgh it isn't just about today
it's about the next day and the day
after that the bright future that our
Pennsylvania has and that our wonderful
city of pittsburgh has I couldn't be any
more honor or pleased to be with you
here today and I thank everyone who was
part of this this very important project
and I look forward to coming back and
seeing it grow and become even bigger
and better in the years to come and
before I walk off there is one
additional person that I would like the
crowd perhaps most of you know but if
you don't and I'm going to ask her to
stand Leslie grummons Baker is here the
chief of staff to the governor I'm going
to pay for that later because she didn't
want that but also a proud daughter of
the Pittsburgh area so the the roots of
Pittsburgh run deep in in our
administration and we couldn't be more
pleased to be a part of this wonderful
event today thank you next we have our
good friend senator Jay Costa not only
does the public private partnership need
to support of the executive branch in
the Commonwealth but we also need the
support of our great state legislators
and Jay gets it he's obviously a local
celebrity around here a person who
screwed up nearby from from a great
family and one that's really understands
what's going on here Jay has been with
us again from the beginning he's
continued to support us we're looking to
the future and the like introduce our
good friend senator Jay Kosta Thank You
Todd thank you very much my staff also
wrote notes for me they confined them to
four cards and I'd like to read them one
stand up to smile three say thank you
for sit down that's
I can tell you lieutenant governor from
time to time we probably wish I would do
that he is our presiding officer and
Harrisburg and but any event let me say
thank you very much and congratulate
everyone involved you heard from the
speakers about what a project like this
means to our region what it means to our
community what it means to our city you
know I grew up in this neighborhood as
the governor said I played baseball off
the street my family grew up on lorimer
and Shetland another area where
tremendous plans are in place and I want
to just congratulate first Todd and Greg
in the bakery square folks for the
tremendous risk that you all talk I mean
this is not something easy at a time
when we were struggling in this
commonwealth in his country these guys
stepped out and the results of that you
see what's taking place here and these
persevered and moved on and I've been
one pleased to be a small part of this
conversation these guys behind me have
really done what needs to be done but it
goes back to this whole notion about
vision and these guys have wonderful
vision about what this place could look
like and it just doesn't extend here it
goes right down the street in the East
Liberty the community that as I said
earlier I used to walk to go to Treasure
Island if folks remember treasure island
or the hot dog place or even the
Carnegie Library that was standing there
the Kingsley house all those things that
are just a stone's throw away we're
decimated over the course of time and as
Michael said this whole community is now
read this whole quarter has been
revitalized and exciting to be a part of
it i want to thank these guys for the
work that they do it is about
partnerships about working with state
government local government county
government city federal government
everyone working together but it's also
partners who make the decision to invest
and what these guys dream and we want to
say thank you to all those folks who
made the commitment to establish the
presence here and be part of what we're
doing here but these guys are doing here
what we're small part of and it happens
because you have these public-private
partnerships and I'd be remiss if I
didn't say that our friends in labor the
work that they do and the contributions
that they've made how important it is to
make certain that these projects are
done on time how important it is the
quality of the workmanship continues to
be outstanding to make certain that the
folks who make a commitment to come here
in Pittsburgh can in fact have some
predictability about when they start
where they start and what quality of the
work that's going to be done so the
tremendous number of partners that are
part of this con
sation this wonderful story today I'm
pleased to be a part of it and i look
forward to governor as we go forward and
Leslie you know bakery square
three-point o bakery living 2.0 whatever
needs to be done we're looking for rate
to hope you guys heard me thank you all
very much Gary another great partner of
ours in this development is the
University of Pittsburgh our good friend
dr. Rorie Cooper here who runs the hurl
the human engineering lab for the VA and
pit he was the first one that committed
to bakery square we went up in the old
freight elevators together and looked
around and he's been a great advocate
and supporter of ours we also have the
vice chancellor for community and
government affairs our friend Paul sup
which was going to say a few words on
behalf the University of Pittsburgh
thank you I'm really here on behalf of
our chancellor mark Nordenberg who very
much would have liked to be here but
could not make it so on behalf of
Chancellor Nordenberg in the university
I just want to extend our thanks and
congratulations to Todd and Greg and
want a capital and acknowledge and thank
the leaders that are sitting behind us
you know as president suresh said and
also Todd stole my thunder and wanting
to acknowledge and thank Rory Cooper who
really was you know among the first
people to walk into to what was then a
shell and have the vision to be able to
share with walnut capital to see what it
could be and really was a pioneer here
here and so we thank you worry for for
that but as president suresh said
pittance emu have worked very hard over
the recent you know 10 or 15 years to
become leaders in technology development
and management and to get the ideas from
the labs out onto the street and into
industry bakery square and now bakery
square to have provided the vital
move-in-ready sites that are in
proximity to the universities as well as
our neighborhoods and they've created
the environment and the opportunities
for our graduates to create startup
businesses to keep their talents here in
Pittsburgh and it's also spread to
positive impacts of pit and CMU into
Pittsburgh's neighborhoods beyond just
Oakland
but as also I I think I can't let this
opportunity pass without also noting
that it really does have special
significance for for me as well like
like a number of the folks have already
said sitting behind me this is I
consider this kind of my neighborhood I
can sit on my back porch and and listen
to the construction and the sounds of
progress and and give Todd a call if
it's too late in the evening but but but
you know Elsa you know I was in the
first graduating class in 1975 as an
eighth grader at reisen Stein middle
school and you know I've watched things
really come full circle and to me bakery
square and bakery square two are really
the shining example of Pittsburgh's
reinvention or resurgence or Renaissance
whatever tag you want to give it and I
just go privileged and honored to be a
part of it today and so thank you very
much on behalf of the University of
Pittsburgh and our Chancellor now we get
to the good part the folks that really
put the the work on the ground the blood
sweat and tears that went into bakery
square are great partner local partners
first I want to introduce Marty Kaminski
the director of engineering construction
the Urban Redevelopment Authority to
come up and say a few words on behalf of
the URA Thank You Todd I'll tell you
this is a great day for Pittsburgh and
it's a great day for the URA and I'm
really happy to be here I'm not a
resident of East Liberty but I did grow
up in the city i'm from beach view and I
to played over at mellon field as a
teenager playing Pony League Baseball
and I got to tell you i would have never
guessed in a million years that I'd be
here before you today having played ball
there and seeing all this great energy
and excitement that bakery square is
kicking into this community I would like
to say that you know in the wake of the
dwindling public money that's been
available for infrastructure it's even
more important as the folks here have
been saying that we continue our public
and private partnerships I mean in that
way we can leverage the dollars that are
needed to make these kind of investments
with the help of folks providing money
through the art cap through the new
transportation funding laws
and our friends at the EDA who in this
case have provided the money for the
infrastructure that's providing the
roads that will support the bakery
square 2 point 0 development this is
this is how things happen this expansion
of bakery square 2 point 0 also helps us
take another important step in our
strategy to bring success not only to
east liberty but to the bordering
neighborhoods of Homewood and larimer
that hopefully can also take advantage
of this growing tech field as a result
of this technology that Google has
prevented or has provided for this
neighbor not prevented and now and I
think it's also important that we
realize that it's a it's very critical
that it's important that we do our
infrastructure in advance of a need in
other words we can't wait until folks
say I need a building or I need a road
to get us what we need we need to be
building ahead of time we need to keep
spending public money to build the
infrastructure snowing folks like Google
and other tech companies are ready to
expand we're ready for them to take
advantage of that opportunity and and
stay in this most livable city of
Pittsburgh that we're so proud of so
with that said I'd like to also to
acknowledge a few folks have been really
instrumental the project obviously the
mayor council executive fitzgerald
councilman Gilman obviously Google the
folks at EDA no one from there was able
to attend today so I want to especially
thank them for their help in providing
the funding for this project obviously
Greg and talk from want a capital their
architect strata who is the architect
for the living Boulevard that we're
building as part of this roadway Hampton
technical services for the engineer for
walnut ms consultants who was the civil
engineer that did do design of the
roadways obviously the pws a our partner
on all the water and sewer facilities
tremble construction management services
has provided the inspection a libero
need construction the contractor and the
trades that are supporting them and my
co-workers at the you're a thank you
very much and enjoy this great
development
not quite last ship and almost now I'd
like to introduce our person you know
well our friend rich Fitzgerald rich and
I have known each other for a long time
we we bumped into each other a lot
playing basketball and scroll up in the
JCC for many many years if I'm trying to
get rich to come back now that he's in
shape he's gonna kick our butts now so
I'd like to see him come back one of
these days but let me introduce rich
Fitzgerald again a great partner VAR has
been really supportive of the project
and get I don't know if you saw the
picture this morning I was dancing with
the mayor yesterday so we're doing
different things that's called zomba I
think it's what they call it I don't
know what that is but that's what we
were supposed to be doing uh you know
this is heady stuff in Pittsburgh you
know yesterday we had the President and
the Vice President as congressman Doyle
talked about and what the president said
when he came here is how Pittsburgh is a
model that the rest of the country
should follow when you hear those kind
of things it's really exciting about
what we did he talked about you know
that the training the community college
and the job training and skill sets that
we've been able to provide and it goes
all the way from you know again the
Community College up to with dr. Suresh
inand University of Pittsburgh are doing
and we think about CMU spitting out 36
companies in one year 36 companies how
we would fight to get one company to
come here and that they're doing it at
that level you know last year 16,000
jobs created in this region is GDP a grp
of over six almost six and a half
percent triple the rate of the National
of average what's happening here is
absolutely terrific and it's not just at
the level again at the CCAC level we're
one of only three regions in the country
in which twenty percent of our young
workforce has a postgraduate degree we
have a brainy City a smart industrial
hard-working city which is a model of
what people can do around this country
you know two weeks ago we had the
governor was here at another
groundbreaking a block from here for the
new transportation project we have
coming on the East busway in my office
because I go to ground breakings every
weak and ribbon cuttings every week I
have more shovels than home depot I have
more scissors than office depot but
that's what's happening in Pittsburgh
right now it's absolutely incredible we
have a lot to be proud of what he
slipper T has become you know and Mike
said it very well the word East Liberty
was it was a almost a word nobody wanted
to use a couple years ago 25 years ago
they built a home a village over there
in east liberty but they didn't call
what he's Liberty Village they called it
shadyside village because they couldn't
use that word to sell those properties
it's an amazing thing what's happening
here in east liberty on Highland Avenue
all the way up through the court or the
east end this whole region is really
that the motto and again we have a lot
to be proud of Todd and Greg what
they've done the partners here the
public-private partnership our
universities as Jay said our trades
they're the ones that I see the
Carpenters are here today rich Easton is
0 from the trades the laborers are here
today Billy Brooks they're the ones who
built those LEED certified sustainable
buildings with the skill set that they
have again we have a lot to be proud of
across the spectrum and this is just one
more proud day for Pittsburgh to join in
so I'm glad to be here taught in great
thank you very much
before I introduce our mayor I want to
thank a few people in the audience
councilman Dan Gilman for representing
the shadyside district has been a great
supporter and friend of ours all along
our good friends from dollar bank who's
been our lead bank and supporting us
from financing standpoint our friends at
Penn trust and the erect funds we talked
about the great support that the Union
laborers have given us I think we have
rich donezo and Paul Quintero here
representing the trade unions they've
been some fantastic partners of ours and
done great work for us Sean Conway is
here representing Senator Pat Toomey
again instrumental in providing the EDA
grant Liz fischbach representing Senator
Bob Casey we had a chance to see the
senator yesterday when the president was
in town and he he sends his regards as
well we mentioned rich Hudak from dced
mailing myers our good friend and
supporter and partner in east liberty
who we love to see come to these events
as the greater Easler erie community
continues to expand I think I've got
anybody don't think anybody I forgot but
now let me introduce our good friend and
Mayor Bill Peduto bill really is truly
invested in this neighborhood as we all
know he's was our councilman before that
he worked for our councilman he's
probably been 30 years in this community
when we when we when we started the
project at bakery square 2 point 0 there
was a little bit of angst between the
neighbors will step forward when he was
the councilman and said this is the way
we need to do it this is the process we
need to go through this is the way we
should attack if this is the way we
bring the community involved we sat down
we organize meetings we met with the
community when we went to Planning
Commission in city council guess what
unanimous support and I think that's
really a credit the bill into his
forethought and now as mayor kind of
taking that through to the new
administration we're just talking
briefly before we started there's a
whole new attitude in the city today
it's a good attitude it's an attitude
that the new Pittsburgh wants that added
to the transparency that attitude of
moving forward that attitude that we can
make anything happen in our city and I
think that's a credit to bill in his
leadership and we really look forward to
working with Bill and continuing this
great partnership we have so I'll let it
reduce our friend and great supporter
Bill Peduto
nation alright so i get to wrap it up a
night that means wrap it up right I
don't have a staff that wrote me any
speeches because they know I ignore them
first off I gotta give praise where
praise as did it councilman Dan Gilman
who really did lead the effort with the
community to make sure there was a lot
of support around this and by the time
that it did get the zoning and planning
and the council there was unanimous
support and there was a feeling between
East Liberty and shady side that this
was their project as well and that's the
way that we need to do things we've got
a great team and there's a there's a
camaraderie between all of us about
wanting to do what is right for the city
and for this region but it really
extends to the people that are in this
room because there's this great
abundance of talent in Pittsburgh it's
not just dr. Cooper it's not just Andrew
Moore and his Andrew here god I wish he
was because he all he had to do was say
two letters and this would be such a
different time all you had to do is say
okay when Google said we need you to
come to Silicon Valley and say said no I
don't want to leave Pittsburgh I can't
do his accent but he won he said he
wanted to stay here and because of that
and there's so much rightfully so so
much media attention about a new cracker
plant in Beaver County but there's going
to be eight hundred engineers around an
old cracker plant in east liberty and on
a whole new economy being built around
it I moved up the street because I could
walk out my door in the morning and
smelt cookies it was amazing I found out
mr. Rogers lived up the street I was
like this is just a fantasy now when I
wake up in the morning I smell
innovation and its exuberant all
throughout this city and if you think
about what's happening right here and
you think about the cathedral of
learning you get like a three-mile piece
of yarn and you go around in a big
circle it is booming everywhere it is
happening and our job is to make sure
that as these developments happen we
create ladders of opportunity to the
other communities that haven't seen it
yet and it's happening there too for
developers and our
100 days wanting to develop in homewood
for developers and 180 wanting to
develop in homewood right across the
street in larimer congressman needs your
help with this 30 million dollars of
federal grant money that's being looked
at to be developed in a community plan
that involved east liberty and larimer
in the kingsley association in a group
put together to see the most
cutting-edge development in the city the
greenest housing options not in squirrel
hill not in shadyside and larimer andrey
identifying an entire community around
it all the development that's happening
down around the arena site in that
ladder of opportunity pushing up into
the hill in the redevelopment the BRT
system that will connect downtown in
Oakland and see development in uptown in
the hill connecting it lawrenceville and
everything that's happening there the
terminal building an extension along the
green Boulevard for 3.2 miles between
downtown and the Highland Park bridge
and connecting it all around you know
back about 20 years ago the college kids
all lived in Oakland now they live in
the south side and they live in
lawrenceville and they live throughout
this city and the universities are
keeping them here our opportunities are
limitless these will be the buildings
that will build off of because the
innovation is already here and there's
going to be more buildings like this and
we're going to see that three mile
radius around the Cathedral learning
extent to Carrick into allentown and to
Sheridan and it's going to stretch from
Manchester to east which town in
throughout this entire city an entire
new industry being built this is a very
special day you're at a very special
moment because we're seeing it right now
happening but soon it's going to happen
all throughout so celebrate today and
understand that there are risk takers
and there are visionaries and there are
those that will put their money in their
back behind developments and we'll see
it happen in that vision and that work
will be done over and over and over
again so thank you guys for having that
vision thank you for putting money
behind it
thanks for helping to build that new
Pittsburgh thanks Bill well again we
appreciate the kind words that everybody
on the on the stage has given to us
today now comes the fun part we get to
go across the street grab a shovel grab
a hardhat take some pictures really see
some some folks at work and see what
progress is all about